hey this is presto Walker here's a
slightly edited version of an email I
received high pressure I got this
problem from a Chinese math teacher it
was used to identify gifted kids for
competition ABCD is a parallelogram in
the diagram the areas of yellow regions
are 8 10 72 and 79 find the area of the
red triangle the diagram is not to scale
the math prerequisites to solve this
problem are basic arithmetic and knowing
the area of the parallelogram and the
area of the triangle I was told a few
Chinese fifth graders solved it in less
than one minute oh well it took me
almost 10 bill from New York so I gave
this problem a try and it was extremely
challenging for me and I just couldn't
figure it out so I replied to bill I
couldn't solve it please let me know the
solution so I'm going to magnify this
problem for you and I'm going to ask you
can you figure out this problem give
this puzzle a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
so here's the magical answer it turns
out to be a simple calculation the area
of the red triangle is 79 plus 10 minus
72 minus 8 which equals 9 Wow
but why is this the answer it's
important to understand the method to
verify the answer and to strengthen
problem-solving skills so even though I
didn't find the answer it was very
exciting for me to understand how the
answer could be solved in such a simple
method bill explained to me the key is
finding a triangle or set of triangles
whose area equals 1/2 the area of the
parallelogram so before I get to the
solution I want to quickly review the
areas of a parallelogram and a triangle
so let's take a parallelogram and we'll
consider the base of the parallelogram
as its length to find the area we draw a
vertical altitude as its height now the
area of a parallelogram is its base
times its height but we can also
calculate it taking the width of the
parallelogram as its base we then draw a
horizontal altitude as its height and we
then use the same formula of base times
height even though we'll be using
different values for its base and its
height this will still give us the area
of a parallelogram
now from this formula we can deduce the
area of a triangle let's draw the
diagonal of this parallelogram and
notice we split it into two equal
triangles so the triangle has half the
area of the parallelogram
therefore the triangle has an area
that's equal to base times the height
divided by 2 we can also use the formula
if we take the base of the triangle as
the width of the parallelogram we then
will want to use the horizontal altitude
as the height so we can use the formula
base times height divided by 2 but we
can look at different sides as the base
furthermore this formula will be true
for triangle that's not even the
diagonal of the parallelogram as long as
it has the same base and the same height
we will still get half the area of the
parallelogram so keep this in mind it'll
be a very useful principle for solving
this problem one more thing that will be
useful is that it doesn't just have to
be one triangle
imagine we have a set of two triangles
that span the length of this
parallelogram and both of them have the
same height as the parallelogram so the
sum of these two triangles areas will
again be equal to the base times the
height divided by two and this will also
be equal to half the area of the
parallelogram this also be true if we
take two triangles that span the width
of the parallelogram so now let's use
these principles to solve the problem we
go to our diagram and the first thing
we'll do is we'll label the remaining
areas we'll write a b c d e and f and
we'll change the question mark the red
triangle into the variable x we want to
solve for x so how do we do that well
let's look for some triangles whose area
will be half the parallelogram one set
of triangles will be these two blue
triangles they span the length of the
parallelogram and they have the same
height as the vertical altitude of the
parallelogram so if we focus on just
these two triangles we can see that
their area will be half the area of the
parallelogram and we can also calculate
their area by adding up these letters we
have X plus a plus 72 plus B plus 8 now
let's look for another triangle whose
area is half the area of the
parallelogram consider this orange
triangle here
this orange triangle spans the width of
the parallelogram and its height is
equal to the horizontal altitude so its
area will also be half the area of the
parallelogram we can write out its area
as a plus seventy nine plus B plus ten
now both of these sets of shapes have an
area that's equal to half the area of
the parallelogram so we can set these
areas equal to each other so we equate
these two formulas for the half the area
of the parallelogram and now we could
solve for X notice that on both sides we
have an a so these will cancel on both
sides we have a B so these will cancel
so we end up with the equation X plus 72
plus 8 is equal to 79 plus 10 we then
solve for x to get 79 plus 10 minus 72
minus 8 which equals 9 and that's how we
get the magical answer but there's also
another way if you picked some other
triangles so I just want to illustrate
that for you because bill also sent that
to me so imagine you take these two
triangles these two triangles span the
length of the parallelogram and they
have a height equal to the vertical
altitude of the parallelogram therefore
their area will be equal to half the
area of the parallelogram the areas of
these two triangles in total will be c
plus 79 plus E Plus D plus 10 plus F now
we'll do the same thing we'll consider a
difference triangle or a different set
of triangles along the width of the
parallelogram so these orange triangles
will have a base that's equal to the
width of the parallelogram and they span
the horizontal altitude of the
parallelogram so together their total
area will be equal to half the area of
the parallelogram their area is equal to
X plus C plus 72 plus T plus E Plus 8
Plus
so now we have two sets of shapes whose
area is equal to half the area of the
parallelogram so we set these areas
equal to each other and we get the
following equation now we'll cancel out
all of the terms that we can we'll end
up canceling everything except for X and
the numbers that we want so we end up
simplifying this to be 79 plus 10 is
equal to X plus 72 plus 8 and we get
exactly the same equation as before and
we again saw that the area of the red
triangle X is equal to 9 so it's quite
remarkable to me that 5th graders in
China were able to solve this in less
than a minute did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
puzzle suggestion or topic suggestion
you can email me at pressure and mind
your decisions comm you can also catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at pressure all Walker